SANDEEP PARIKH: --for joining
us this morning, folks.
So today, Rob and I
are going to talk about
how do you manage
configuration, policies,
and resources at scale?
My name is Sandeep Parikh,
I'm an Anthos advocate
for Google Cloud.
ROB LEIDLE: And I'm Rob Leidle.
I'm a software engineer
for Google Cloud.
SANDEEP PARIKH: All right, so
let's start with configuration.
So if you take a step
back and you sort of
look at the high level
view of the Anthos stack,
you start at the bottom.
We start with Kubernetes, and
then you layer in service mesh
on top of that.
And then we've got to
layer for policy controls,
which we'll get to shortly.
And then you've got your
application services.
And then on the left
side of the diagram,
we talk about how you get
configuration or applications,
how you get software into that
environment, those two things.
And this is the typical
sort of approach
we're trying to guide
customers around
as they think about how to
setup, deploy, and operate
an Anthos environment.
So to start, we're going to
focus on config management.
How do you get
objects and resources
configured in your deployment?
Now how do you deliver
that configuration?
So typically, what we still
see on a pretty regular basis
is that a lot of teams are
still kubectl to apply changes
to their environments.
They're still doing very
imperative operations.
And this is really
challenging because,
as these clusters grow,
not only in number
but in scale and size--
we see a lot of large-scale
multi-tenant deployments--
it can become challenging
for operator teams
to continue to use kubectl
or imperative approaches
because Kubernetes itself
is a declarative system.
You declare what you want the
state of the cluster to be,
and you push that configuration.
But that doesn't really match
up to imperative operations.
So how do you transition that
sort of imperative approach
to one that fits the Kubernetes
model better, that's more
declarative in nature?
And the first step is we take
out that imperative approach,
and we replace it with
a central repository
where you store that
configuration information.
So we start with
a Git repo, which
is something almost every
technical practitioner is
familiar with.
You start with Git.
And inside of that Git repo, we
store all of the configuration
about your cluster,
how you configure
your namespaces, any additional
metadata, labels, annotations,
pods, services, secrets,
volumes, you name it.
If it's a Kubernetes object,
it can fit in that config repo.
And what we're doing
with that is we're
trying to create
this sort of approach
where the state of the cluster
is what exactly matches
the state of your repository.
So if it's not in
the Git repo, it's
not reflected in
your cluster as well.
Once you adopt
that approach, that
state that you're
trying to declare,
becomes-- that configuration,
it's effectively data.
And we store it just
like we store code.
And because we're using
something that's like Git,
it becomes a process that
you can use typical software
development workflows to manage
your configuration manager
environments.
So the process of deploying
a new config in production
follows the same software
development process
that you're already
familiar with, right?
If a team needs to create
a new configuration,
they can branch the repository,
they can make their changes,
they can validate them
locally, and then they
can have them merge back in.
And then those changes get
pushed out to production.
And as I mentioned,
at any given time,
we want to make sure the
state of your deployments
matches exactly what's
specified in that Git repo.
And so that's where Anthos
Config Management comes in.
So with ACM, what
we're trying to give
you is the ability to define
the state of your deployment
and store that in a central,
secure Git repository.
The benefits of doing
that are the same benefits
that apply to typical
software development, right?
We have the ability to audit
changes a lot more cleanly now.
Instead of digging through
Kubernetes logs and events
and trying to figure
out who made a change
and what change they introduced
that might have broken
your infrastructure, we can just
trace that back to a set of Git
commits and who authored the
commit and maybe even who
merged it in.
You can revert your deployment
and roll things back
a lot easier just by making
a change in your Git config.
You may revert a commit, and
now production can pick up
that revert they needed to do.
ACM also is self-healing.
So it watches the cluster for
drift from the configuration.
So if, by chance, someone
goes and applies an imperative
operation and changes a
namespace configuration
outside of the normal workflow,
the mechanism built into ACM
will actually sink that
change back in and put it
back to the state that's, again,
reflected in the repository.
So at any given time, again,
the state of your cluster
and the state of your deployment
matches exactly what's
in source control.
And ultimately, the
best part of this
is that you can version your
deployments just like you
version software.
So you can tag them, mark
them as release candidates,
et cetera, just like you would
any of your applications.
So it's a pretty
powerful thought process
to work through.
Now, the way Anthos
Config Management, or ACM,
works in your environment from
an architectural perspective--
and you can see, in the
middle of the diagram,
there's the interconnect, right?
That's bridging your on-prem
environment and your cloud
environment.
And this would be true for a
multi-cloud scenario as well.
But what's happening
here is that you've
got the interconnect bridging
the networking between the two.
And then, in each Kubernetes
environment or each GKE
environment, there's a
config management controller
that we deploy as an operator.
And that controller is
what's keeping things in sync
with the repo.
Now, the best part is that repo
does not have to live on cloud.
That can live in your
on-prem infrastructure.
So if you want to
make sure-- if there
are particular security or
compliance or guidelines
around where your
configuration lives,
where the definition
of that lives,
you can keep that on-prem
and then have the config just
spread out across all
of your GKE clusters.
So that's a little bit about
how we manage configuration
at scale, right?
And let me go back for
a quick second here.
So the way you configure
ACM is, you effectively,
when you deploy the software
inside of your Kubernetes
environment, all you
really have to tell
it is, where does
that Git repo live,
what is the branch
or the tag you want
to use for your releases,
and any authentication
information it needs too
to access that Git repo.
And once you've done
that, it's up and running.
And now your clusters are
under that managed state
that ACM provides.
So that's the config
management piece.
Now, how do we use
config management
to implement policy controls?
So the sort of act of creating
policies and enforcing them
is something we often
call policy management.
Think of policies
and policy management
as effectively
saying, I have a set
of rules, a set of
governance I want
to apply to all of
my environments,
to all of my deployment.
And I want to enforce those
rules in certain ways.
Either I want to not allow
objects that break those rules.
Or I want to allow objects
that may violate those rules,
but I want to be able
to audit them and audit
any of those violations
on an ongoing basis.
Now policy management
and config management,
there's a little bit of overlap.
And I think, from a
mental model perspective,
there's sometimes a
little bit of collapsing
these two together.
But they are very distinct,
especially in the way
that ACM sees them.
So from a config
management perspective,
config management is
really all about how
do you store, control,
and govern your deployment
configuration.
There is typically a process
for how it gets done.
In the case of ACM, that's
a GitOps-style process.
And there's typically
a process for who
can do it using something like
Kubernetes role-based access
control, or RBAC,
to control that.
But ultimately,
config management
is really about how you
enforce object or resource
state in the cluster.
On the other hand, policy
management is about rules.
It's about setting guardrails
and applying governance.
And it's really more about,
can you make a change
to a given object?
Is that change allowed?
And how do we want to
enforce those changes?
Do we want to, again,
deny them entirely
or allow those changes
to happen and then
audit them for kind
of ongoing violations?
A lot of times, I think
the policy management angle
can actually sound quite
a bit like Kubernetes
RBAC in many ways.
But again, if you
think about it,
RBAC is about who
can make a change
and who has the power
to make a change.
Whereas, the policy
aspect is really about,
is that change even allowed?
So it's a little bit of a higher
level view of the problem.
Now, I mentioned
guardrails and governance.
Kubernetes is an incredibly
powerful distributed system,
right?
And powerful systems
like that typically
need some kind of control
because you want to watch out
for potential problem spots.
You want to make sure you
haven't given a particular set
of users too many privileges.
You don't want to give them
too much power to make changes.
You want to make sure that
services are locked down
and that they can
only be accessed
by other services
you deem appropriate
or by certain parties
you deem appropriate.
And obviously, you
want to watch out
for things like exfiltration.
You don't want data
leaving your environments
in an unintended fashion.
But on the other
hand, those controls
that you want to
use, that governance,
needs to be agile and flexible.
You want to be able to
scope that governance
and that control very narrowly
to only the objects you really
care about.
And you want those
policies and those controls
to be written by
the people who know
the compliance, the regulatory
work, your organization's
policies best.
So you've got to make it easy
to develop and deploy them.
Because at the end of the day,
what we're trying to get to
is safe deployments.
We don't want
anything in production
that could violate
any of the rules
we need to worry about
on a regular basis.
So as part of ACM, we
have another component
wrapped in there called
ACM Policy Controller.
Policy Controller is
based on a project
from Open Policy
Agent and Gatekeeper.
Gatekeeper is an offshoot
of Open Policy Agent.
And Open Policy Agent is really
just a general purpose policy
engine.
You write a policy,
you hand it some data,
it makes a decision based
on those two things.
Does that data
violate the policy,
or does it not
violate the policy?
And what Gatekeeper and,
by extension, ACM Policy
Controller do is it
takes that policy engine,
and it makes it a first-class
citizen in your Kubernetes
environment.
And it makes it into an
admission controller.
So now that means
the policy mechanism
is right alongside the
ability to admit objects
to the cluster.
So now you can apply
rules upon admission.
And so something that
could potentially
violate the rules that your
organization has won't get
admitted to the cluster.
Or again, you could say
things like, well, I
want to allow this
to happen, but I
want to audit anyone who's
potentially out of compliance.
It has that sort of capability.
But because it
integrates, again,
as a first-class
citizen with Kubernetes,
and with GKE by extension,
all of the standard Kubernetes
tooling you're used to, it
fits right alongside with it,
can be used alongside with it.
So let's talk about
a policy in depth
and what the
structure looks like.
So there are two parts
to a policy, right?
There is the rule
definition, which
is written in a
language called Rego,
which is part of the OPA
package, the Open Policy Agent
package.
And then there's the actual
packaging of that rule
and giving it to Kubernetes.
And so that packaging is
called a ConstraintTemplate.
And it's a parametrized piece.
You can apply arguments.
You can scope it down.
But ultimately,
the policy approach
is built into two components.
One is the rule definition.
And the second part is how
that rule gets enforced.
So the ConstraintTemplate
here that you see
is the rule definition.
What are we trying to enforce?
What are we trying to evaluate?
How many of you are familiar
with Istio in the room?
All right, a handful.
So you'll hear more
about Istio later today.
But one of the most
powerful aspects of Istio
is that you can automatically
enable things like MTLS
to mutually
authenticate services
and clients in your cluster.
But one of your
organization's policies
could be, hey, we
want to make sure
that every service
that gets deployed,
every client in our environment,
must support mutual TLS.
And you want to also make sure
that no one turns that off,
right?
You don't want anyone
to bypass that,
because that could be possible.
Someone who has the appropriate
RBAC permissions could say,
well, my service is special.
I want to turn off
MTLS because we
don't want to support it today.
So what this rule
is actually doing
is it's evaluating part of
that process and saying,
hey, if you try to turn off
MTLS, I'm going to catch that,
and that's going to
throw a violation.
So this is the rule
that catches that.
And then the enforcement
half is packaged in something
called a constraint.
And let me jump
back a quick second.
But what we're
doing in this policy
and this ConstraintTemplate is,
if you look at that kind field
about a third of
the way down, we're
actually defining a new custom
resource for Kubernetes.
We're saying, hey, there
is now a new resource
called,
destinationruletlsenabled,
that lives in the
Kubernetes environment.
And if you actually
run kubectl get CRDs,
you'll see that on the list.
So what the constraint
does is it actually
takes that, CR and it creates
another spec based around that.
And it lets us scope
the enforcement.
And so there are two parts of
this that are really important.
One is enforcement action
about a third of the way down.
In this example, I've set
this constraint to be denied.
So if anybody tries to submit
a destination rule that
deactivates MTLS, that thing
will get denied admission
to the cluster entirely.
It won't even get in.
And the second part of
it is, about halfway
down, where I'm actually scoping
that to a particular API object
and to a particular namespace.
So I'm saying, only
scope this rule
to destination rule objects
that are part of the Istio API,
and only look for them
in the default namespace.
Now, the nice thing is,
with ACM Policy Controller,
you can actually adjust
that scoping a little bit.
You can say, I want to have
it apply to any namespace
that has the following
labels or that doesn't
have the following labels.
So you can actually control
the enforcement and application
of that constraint as well.
And so now, what
would happen if we
were to push that
ConstraintTemplate
and that corresponding
constraint,
if I try to push this new
destination rule that disables
MTLS, GKE will
accept the object.
The admission controller will
then review it, and then decide
and see that it violates
the rule we've laid out
and then just kick it
right back and say,
sorry, we can't take it.
And you can supply your
own custom error messages
and things like that.
But it will automatically
just push that object back out
and say, I can't accept
this, because, again, it
violates a rule.
So now, there are three stages
to the policy development
process.
There's obviously
the authoring step,
which is where you're
going to validate
the rules in your approach.
And then there's the
application of it
where you may want
to just firmly deny
anything that is
out of compliance
or that violates your rules.
Or there's a third
step where you
can say we want to allow
objects in that may potentially
have violations, and we
just want to audit them.
And there are
things where you may
want audit controls for
maybe labels or annotations.
But for something that's
violating-- again,
regulatory compliance or any
kind of corporate IT policy--
those may be objects
where you want
to deny admission entirely.
Again, we want to watch out for
things like data exfiltration
or overexposed services.
So some of the example policy
use cases-- and by the way,
I should mention there are
actually a whole bunch that
are already included with
ACM Policy Controller, things
like checking for
required labels
or particular annotations
or a particular structure.
You can do things with
policies like make sure
that resource constraints
are baked in, right?
You could say, hey,
no pods and services
can be deployed in this cluster
unless they actually call out
how much CPU and RAM they
need so that we can make
sure that we're not overdoing
the amount of resources we're
going to consume for a
given pod or service.
But particularly around
security concerns,
we can watch out for things
like only allowing access
from certain domains within
your organization, right?
So a service within a particular
domain can access another one,
but one outside of
that list of domains
may not be able to
access services.
Like in the example
I showed earlier,
we can require strict
MTLS across the board
and make sure that
stays enforced
so that no one can turn off
that authentication piece.
You may want to implement
controls like service A can
talk to a service B, but
service A definitely cannot talk
to service C, and
make that a policy.
So again, if anyone tries to
bypass that or override it,
they will actually get booted.
That configuration won't be
allowed into their cluster.
And there are many
other examples.
These are just a few.
And we're happy to kind of
answer questions around them
as we have time to afterwards.
So with that, I'm going
to hand it off to Rob
to talk about managing
platform resources.
ROB LEIDLE: Yeah,
so thanks Sandeep.
Kind of bringing
this together, how
could you apply
the same techniques
Sandeep talked about to
your cloud infrastructure?
That's not possible today.
You're going to have some
sort of split-brain approach.
You're going to have
Kubernetes applications managed
through your
Kubernetes tool chain.
And then you're going to have
your cloud resources managed
through some other mechanism,
be it cloud or Develop
Manager, et cetera.
We have now made available a new
product, GCP Config Connector.
And this allows you to manage
your cloud infrastructure
in a Kubernetes native way.
And since it is
Kubernetes native,
integrations like Anthos Config
Management just work with it.
The idea here is that
kubectl, Config Management,
or API clients--
I guess kubectl
is an API client--
but API clients like
your CI/CD pipeline.
And they can push configuration
to the Kubernetes API server.
And then GCP Config
Connector will
take that declared
configuration,
your intended state, and it
will make it a reality in GCP.
So Config Connector, like I
said, is Kubernetes native.
The actual configuration
is the care
you've come to expect
from Kubernetes.
You can use the K8s APIs or
kubectl to manipulate it.
It allows you to declare
your intended state
with declarative configuration.
So you avoid a lot
of the issues that
come from imperative workflows.
It is eventually consistent.
So you can apply
your configuration
in any order you want,
and it will eventually
reach the state you intend.
That also means that it'll be
quicker and more performant.
It's item potent.
You can apply the same
configuration over and over
again, and you'll see no change.
And it combats drift.
So you can ensure that changes
made by operators outside
of your application's CI/CD
push flow are reverted back.
So you don't end
up in a state where
there are changes that are
not in your repository.
It's available through
Anthos as a GKE
add-on or manual installation.
And it's in beta now
and going GA in Q1.
So here's a little talk
about the actual KRM.
On the right, we
have two examples.
We have a Pub/Sub topic--
which Pub/Sub is a
popular GCP service.
And topic is a resource
within Pub/Sub.
And then we have a
Pub/Sub subscription.
A subscription is
associated with a topic.
That's just the way
subscriptions work.
And in this example, you can
see in the subscriptions spec,
we have a field called topicRef.
And in topicRef, we say
the name is my-topic.
And that's saying
this subscription
is associated with that topic.
And that's just an example of
how these configurations work
in the way you would expect a
Kubernetes resource to work.
And in terms of what
resources are supported,
we support resources from all
the services listed there,
notably Compute,
Spanner, Storage.
and resource coverage
is expanding.
So putting it all
together, you can
use your Anthos configuration
and policy management
to manage your GCP
infrastructure as well.
You can bring all those
techniques to GCP.
In addition, you can
standardize your tool chain
on Kubernetes tools,
which will simplify
your environment for developers
and make them more productive.
That'll give you back more of
your most limited resource,
which is developer time.
And you'll have more time
to work on your applications
and things that matter
to your business.
And that's it for policy
configuration management.
Sandeep and I and
other Googlers are
available to answer any
questions as needed.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SANDEEP PARIKH: [INAUDIBLE]